i want you to stop for a second and
think about when i say customer
experience for you what does that mean
if you're anything like the students
that i normally see in class
what you think about your customer
experience is literally the time in
which the customers interact with
whatever
service person you have in your
organization
that's the kind of answer that i
typically get when people think about
customer experience but then what i do
is i ask people
talk to me about your last vacation and
i want you to spend a minute and think
about your last vacation
describe to yourself or sort of recreate
in your mind what that experience was
like
but when i asked them about their
experience as
going on vacation they talk about
planning the vacation
anticipating the vacation what they do
when they go on vacation and then the
memories
that they have from vacation the
customer experience is not
simply the very narrow interaction with
your product
it also includes a before and after
and those befores and afters are
critical to how people understand your
product and for your likelihood of
achieving the holy grail which is word
of mouth
so in psychology we talk about three
sources of utility
utility is kind of like a measure of
psychological well-being more utility is
something better
anticipated utility how much utility
will i get
okay i think about buying a car my
experience with the car is not just
driving the car but it's also
thinking about which car to buy getting
excited about that car
experience utility how much utility or
how much well-being am i experiencing
from
the actual use of the product itself
okay and this is typically when people
think about
the customer experience they really
focus on the experience utility
component
retrospective utility what do i remember
this to be like
and the memory is extremely important
because the memory is what's going to
determine your word of mouth
all three of those need to be managed to
create a really truly winning customer
experience
experiences aren't flat right you don't
sort of experience the same thing at all
times
you have a moment of delight you have a
moment of despair you have a moment of
meh
the way memory works is in terms of
snapshots
i remember moments in that experience
and why is that so critical because it
tells you that what you need to manage
is not the film
but it's specific kind of moments